il y a un smartphone qui va sortir avec
un toucher papier c'est next paper une
technologie de TCL qui est super
intéressante vous avez peut-être déjà vu
des tablettes avec cette technologie
next paper TCL vient présenter de
nouvelles qui vont arriver en France
bientôt qui sont intéressantes on a la
dizaine avec un écran de 10,1 pouces en
Full HD ça va également arriver au
niveau d'un ordinateur cette technologie
elle permet quoi et bien elle permet
d'avoir vraiment se toucher papier qui
est super doux et ça va arriver
également sur un smartphone le Next
paper phone qui devrait potentiellement
arriver dans le courant de l'année 2023
cette technologie n'expliqueer elle
permet quoi elle permet d'avoir un
toucher déjà beaucoup plus doux lorsque
vous venez mettre votre doigt en contact
avec l'écran de votre smartphone ça
c'est très très cool et surtout d'avoir
l'impression de lire un écran de
smartphone avec un filtre papier c'est
très doux c'est sympa ça protège en plus
de la lumière bleue donc à côté qui est
très protecteur pour vos yeux et si vous
voulez acheter une tablette et vous
prenez le stylet qui va avec et bien
vous avez l'impression je dis à
l'impression d'écrire sur un bout de
papier c'est un écran que je trouve très
réactif qui est assez sympa à voir ça
pourrait vous intéresser est-ce que vous
pourriez être client d'une technologie
next paper d'un smartphone avec la
technologie next paper marqué le moi
dans les commentaires